one two switch here we go let's have
some fun once you switch lacks depth its
list of 28 minigames means it has
variety but most of those games don't
have much long-lasting fun or replay
value once he switches minigames will
have your shooting Cowboys strumming an
air guitar cradling a baby to sleep and
more and while not every activity is a
hit the game is still great fun in the
right environment like Wii Sports before
it won two switches designs show off the
hardware at launches with minigames like
wizard sword fight and runway attempt to
show off the joy Kahn's impressive
motion tracking by wrapping them in
quirky activities that are also easy to
pick up and play on the moon while
Wizards TV based mirroring of your
real-life duel means it works well many
of the other motion based games
especially table tennis and baseball
suffer due to the lack of a visual aid
hitting a ball between two players is
kind of tricky when there's no physical
or virtual ball to hit these games rely
on timing and the ability to hear a ball
coming your way but the timing often
seems random Plus parties don't tend to
be the most quiet of environment which
is a bit of a problem for a party game
this lack of feedback leads to either a
frustrating loss or a hollow win meaning
these minigames are often the ones
relegated to the bottom of the pile far
better are the ones that use the joy
calms motion to supplement the HD Rumble
and the TV screen safe crack and joy
calm rotation both use the joy Kahn's
accelerometers and vibration to great
effect while also giving you helpful
cues on-screen once you switch really
shines however when it has you look away
from the TV and into your opponent's
eyes quick-draw which tests who owns the
quicker trigger finger and Samurai
training where one player has to predict
the swing of their opponent's sword of
both captivating and hilarious
these can still suffer in a noisy
environment it's immediately more social
and engaging to stare into your enemy's
soul as you work them on the head with a
pretend sword locking eyes with an
opponent spaghetti western soundtrack
blaring hand hovering over your trusty
Nintendo branded revolver is peeled for
that fire command you can cut the
tension with a joy con and that makes it
even funnier when you're unintentionally
hurry your controller across the room
that serves me right for ignoring the
wrist straps eye contact is also key to
a number of ones who switches more
suggestive games many of the games high
points are centered around euphemisms of
shall we say lewd act milk sees you put
on the teats of a virtual cow eating
contest involves holding a joy con close
to your face to eat footlong sub day and
soda shake has you shaking an imaginary
bottle of soda until it bursts showering
liquid around the virtual room these
minigames are all dressed up innocently
enough of course but quite clearly
designed to breed thoughts of a more
x-rated nature some may call it vulgar
but seeing your friends faces as they
realize the hand gestures they're making
serves up some of the funniest moments 1
to 2 which has to offer unfortunately
even these highlights were thin all too
soon when playing with the same people
wanting to which has considerable
brethren it's variety of activities but
the lack of depth in those activities is
reflected in its lasting appeal every
new person I introduced to the game
enjoyed their time with it and seeing
them play these games for the first time
renewed my own buzz but playing any one
minigame more than a handful of times
with the same people Lisa that buzz
fading rapidly the dirtier games suffer
motionless since there are OneNote joke
a funny one but one note all the same
the only ones to survive the fading
appeal of those that either have a
high-score component or a layoff
strategy like samurai training or fake
drill which is identical to quick-draw
the announce will fool you with red
herrings like fruit or file
but even the high scoring games are a
wasted opportunity
no leaderboards or Wii sport style skill
level trackers mean you only find out
what the record for the quickest shot is
when you break it
starving once you switch of any real
meta competition element overall then
once you switch feels a little like a
wasted opportunity many of its minigames
are duds that are too limited to be fun
on their first attempt let alone their
hundred and the remainder mostly don't
have the depth to maintain a consistent
and a high to warrant many play throughs
with the same crowd there's no doubt one
two switch should have been packed in
with a Nintendo switch and the decision
to sell it separately goes against every
fiber of its DNA and yet at its best
once you switch deliver some hilarious
moments seeing an uninitiated friend
milk a cow looking into your dad's eyes
as you beat into the trigger and
quick-draw and making a fool of yourself
strutting down runways catwalk is all
amazing fun even if it is short-lived
does it live up to eSports not a chance
but that doesn't stop once you switch
being an enjoyable minigame collection
just make sure you've got enough willing
friends to maintain your own fading high
pose finish
[Music]